we're deeply disappointed
their position is irresponsible and
frankly dangerous
alongside other member station member
[ __ ] states around the world
we continue to call for china to provide
the needed access to data
and samples and this is critical so we
can understand to prevent the next
pandemic this is about saving lives in
the future
and it's not a time to be stonewalling
so will statements like that work the
white house putting china on blast for
blocking phase two
in the investigation of the origins of
covet think that'll change anything
uh morgan ortegas is the former state
department spokesperson she worked for
mike pompeo
uh morgan good morning to you the the
word there from jinsaki was
irresponsible
you think
it's beyond irresponsible the white
house is is right in their condemnations
but i think it's going to take more
because we started these same
condemnations and the same call for
transparency
a year and a half ago all the stuff that
you're seeing in the news right now
that's been reported we knew all this
stuff
a year and a half ago and in fact as
mike pompeo's spokesperson
we did an off the record briefing with
major major anchors around america
gave them this information everything
that you're seeing reported now about
com
the possibility of come in a lab the
only person who ran with it
at the time was bret baer and we had
every major
network represented on that call when we
said guys look at this information
so that's why mike pompeo and i started
talking about this a year and a half ago
in february of 2020
while in munich germany mike pompeo
started warning the world
uh that we that china needed to be
transparent needed to be open
and those calls were largely ignored
bill what
what consequence has china suffered for
the fact that they have lied
to the world about the origins of coven
germany is still pushing for trade deals
right so is the rest of europe they
haven't suffered uh economically they've
suffered from a pr perspective i think
people know that they lied
um and that they continue to lie but
they're not really having any
repercussions
you're exactly right about that what's
the administration going to do about
that however what would your former boss
do yeah what would the former president
trump do
well that's a very good question i mean
we started so
first we started by calling this out and
saying telling the world hey you
you guys need to pay attention to this
one of the things that we did which is
very controversial at the time is we
as you remember pulled funding from the
who now the lead up to that
is mike pompeo and our team at the state
department had been telling the who for
a long time
listen guys you have to have a real
investigation into the origins of covet
we're not saying
explicitly it's the lab but just taking
uh
china's first excuse that it came from a
bat came from
from a wet market was everyone just
accepted this without
any plausible evidence without any of
the things that you need to find the
origins
of kovid and so we warned the who we
warned the who we wore the who and
finally we pulled funding
and everybody uh thought that this was
uh you know so controversial at the time
now we're waking up
two sham investigations later from the
who
tadros now has egg on his face and has
to say well actually the chinese
aren't uh cooperating with us like sort
of
you know obviously you know morgan
um the tokyo games are underway right
now tokyo is 13 hours ahead of new york
city
but in about 16 days they're going to
have a handoff ceremony in tokyo
for the beijing winter games that are
only seven months away
i was watching the feed earlier today
everyone
in that stadium all the athletes or no
there are no
spectators they're all wearing a mask
and they're going to have a handoff
ceremony that the world's going to watch
while the beijing participants will be
wearing masks as well
now how's the international community
going to react when you could still have
the possibility of going to beijing
china next february
with the pandemic still underway in
parts of the world
what will they say what will our our
nation's leaders do
how will they condemn the chinese
communist party
will they boycott the games these are
big questions
that are not too far away morgan
no and you're totally right bill and we
should be dealing with them now
remember what happened in january of
2020. there were eight
at least eight chinese doctors and
scientists who were whistleblowers who
just disappeared
right china was digging mass graves was
preventing
uh travel out of wuhan while lying to
the wh
and telling them no we have no new cases
right that was going on in january
of 2020. so we still don't know the
origins of this virus and we may never
know if china doesn't open up and if
they don't suffer any repercussions
for not allowing the transparency but on
the beijing olympics as i talk about
often
on this on this network it's not just
coveted that we have to look
at bill there is a genocide that both
the trump and the biden administrations
have concurred
is happening in xinjiang in china
against muslim uighurs a genocide
would we participate in a genocide an
olympics in
any other country where genocide is
actively taking place
i don't think so why are we doing it in
china these are massive questions that
we're going to get to them they're not
too far off as i mentioned
in all likelihood we will not be able to
determine the origins of covid
before those games get underway think
about that morgan thank you so much hope
you have a terrific weekend thanks for
coming back with us
today thanks